hello welcome to ET live I'm so fish
Laci joining me today is Iggy Azalea
thank you so much for being here thank
you
I'm so excited about the new music the
new EP is survived the summer coming on
a third and we've got two new tracks out
so far yes they're both kind of a little
bit of a departure for you they're a
little different I would say than what
we've heard before they're definitely a
departure from my album that kind of but
this sort of like a gues resurgence
almost to our nod to my earlier like
mixtape stuff that I did before I got
signs a hum so it's both it feels new
but it feels nostalgic at the same time
sure is that a kameez for you yeah yeah
we know for other people for me I've
heard all my stuff yeah for me it feels
it feels nostalgic which is really kind
of funny pop parallels yeah that's fun
yeah so is this a good reflection of
what we can expect on the EP as well
yeah well okay okay
yeah because it's just an EP so it's six
songs it's short and sweet and I wanted
just to have something that people can
play through all six songs and have the
same kind of energy
so it's pretty reflective was that kind
of a conscious decision that you were
like I really want to go back to my
roots on this one okay okay now the
cream video is out now can your ass on
that you actually posted that you were
surprised by all the I was getting what
were you expecting
[Laughter]
[Music]
well you were apprehensive about
releasing it no I look I I mean I think
everything that I do is something I
would stand behind and love or I
wouldn't do it all right
especially music videos because I put
you know I do all my creative direction
in odd direction for them sorry now I'm
watching yeah so so I always 100%
believe in them but just cuz you know
I've been away for
time and I haven't been consistently
putting out music so I feel like people
I just didn't think people would really
be chat like checking for me or what I'm
doing so I think I was surprised in that
way I I believe that cream is a great
song them video yeah so it's not in a
way that's like really I think that's
good because I think it's great but I
just I'm more surprised like really guys
you guys remembered I'm alive well Missy
Elliott called the song I know she's
absolutely like all-time greatest
inspiration of all time of old stiff
female rappers so it was like I woke up
and saw that yesterday morning and I
just went crazy yeah yeah have you
spoken to her no I've never met her
before she's one celebrity or a person
period that like I think I would really
I wouldn't be able to not fangirl over
if I ever got to meet her yeah she's
like yeah yeah like me and my friend
when I growing up used to get and we got
in a fight about buying a Missy Elliott
album because I bought a Missy Elliott
album and then she bought a Missy
Elliott album for Christmas and I was
like why are you copying me trying to
have the same CD as me my thing this
might be Missy Elliott is my thing so
yeah I really are taking this earlier
really seriously oh that is too funny
you also got a shout out actually from
you got a complicated history but
Azealia Banks did you see that she
tweeted about it genuinely didn't say
that but she's always tweeting I think
about everything well I think she is
somebody had tweeted that your video is
out and she said that she thought you
did a good job and that you looked sexy
in the video I'll take it to today I
don't know if she changes her mind so
much but for today I will take the
couple all right I don't know if those
still stand next week but I'll take it
for today there's always something
different with you two yeah
have you heard any of her new stuff
she's got Treasure Island out now to be
honest I haven't no no none to be Shady
or anything just you know I released
cream and took us no trip like three
days ago so I'm just being like it's
been really surreal the last three days
because I didn't think that I would have
this reception so I mean so I haven't
even listened to scorpion yeah by the
Drake album I really wanted I won't need
to do that too but I was rushing so much
trying to get the music video for cream
edited in time because I'm crazy and I
sit in and do everything and it was also
lost minute trying to meet all the
deadlines that the loss like 12 days of
my life have been like good crazy but I
haven't been sleeping or I've just been
like my own stuff so I need to really
sit down and hear everybody else's
projects is your EP done now yes
submitted submitted iTunes has it I no
longer have its time it's the end I
can't do anything more to it I have
literally sent it off and it's yeah
there's no no more otherwise I would be
by the way because I've had thoughts I
mean how do you stop tinkering with I
would still be tinkering right now ever
since creeps come out I'm like maybe I
could have redone that bridges mm-hmm
but I'll go on forever like that unless
somebody physically takes it out of my
hands and sounds like enough so yeah
it's so here we are sent and that's that
and nobody wants to hear anything more
about it over at my labels alright well
I see some questions coming in from
YouTube and Facebook keep them coming
you guys Phoenix from YouTube wants to
know can you tell us a little bit more
about the collab that you have coming
out with a female rapper
I don't have one coming out anymore you
know what that really sucks what
happened well I was working with this
new girl whose unsigned - I really like
and I'm still helping her she was
working with a producer that I was
working with this guy detail he
produce drunken love really good songs
and she ended up actually having to file
a restraining order against him and
press criminal charges against him for
sexually harassing her oh wow so that
collaboration that we did together fell
apart fell apart but I'm still good
friends with her and working with her so
I'm sure we'll have more collaborations
in future what's really unfortunate that
happened but you know of course I can't
support that and who would want to be on
a song together with like with that guy
yeah that's about the me to movement
kind of going on right now and and how
you're seeing it in the music industry
as a female rapper liking my way like I
mean do you see anything changing do you
not unfortunately no I wish no I think
that there are a lot of steps forward
that we need to take in the music
industry as far as accountability for
that kind of thing when it comes to the
way that we treat women especially women
that are not in power positions or that
are up and coming you know the girl that
I'm talking about now know who I'm
working with is like the classic example
of that kind of thing and it happens all
the time
so I think I saw a lot of great things
happening and women like coming together
and using their voices in the last year
with me too for film related things but
I didn't see as much happening in music
saw some good stuff other Grammys and
stuff like that but I still think
obviously if we're talking about what
we're talking about mm yeah it is a long
way forward they could go I think as a
woman sure sure but I appreciate
appreciate any steps forward but
probably there's more miles to go more
to go exactly now
prior to releasing the songs you had
tweeted that you mg you to you that um
she was trying to sabotage you is that
no I didn't think that was sabotaging me
okay don't be weird they were being
weird they were being weird what's
happening now the creams I'm in tonight
is that because you stood up and you
said something uh you know what I don't
know what they were doing maybe they
really were having like some weird
technical malfunctions I don't know I
just wasn't getting I I'm really
involved so I'll call and ask the tech
person or whoever like so what's going
on with this what's happening with this
and I just felt like I was getting
really uh like like telemarketer type
answers about like well it will be up in
the next 48 hours and I was like well
this is like what does that mean why oh
maybe because it was to maybe he felt
like I wouldn't it was too technical or
beyond my limit maybe that's why he was
giving me like very broad answers but I
was like I don't know this just seems I
don't understand why you're kind of like
giving me the walk around on a real
answer but then it it it's online if one
online and a few hours after that so
yeah
tech problem so I love that you're the
one that gets on the phone oh I gotta
hide not a manager not it you're like no
I'm making this call I was on the firm
with the legal department actually you
know what the legal departments great
shout out to one of the girls up there
is a woman that is the head of that and
she's really cool and funny I was like
do people really get sued over ovens
because I had an oven logo that I twerk
on an oven in the video and I had an
oven and like YouTube wear it out I was
like but it's a no it's a prop oven it's
not they don't even manufacture it
anymore and she was like with being sued
over ovens in the past
eggie I know you think it's crazy we
haven't asked like girl I believe you
then okay I believe
that's crazy but yeah I talk to them I
talk to everybody up there I'm crazy I
call alcohol I call you know now I got
to know the story behind Tokyo snow trip
fans can get it right now if you
preorder the EP you said you tweeted a
little bit about that there was a story
behind it yeah what was it about
somebody we know yeah it is it's someone
famous it's somebody that you know okay
wait give me something timeline like
what where did this inspiration come
from I think at the time that I wrote it
which wasn't too long ago maybe a few
months ago I just felt like in the past
when I would see stuff or negative
things like said about me I would always
respond on Twitter or with words and I
was like you know I'm gonna stop doing
that I'm just gonna like stop putting
anything like that into my music and so
I guess you see a bit about in Tokyo
Sinatra okay
she just sips the tea you guys it's more
interesting that way yeah and I think
you know like that's how rap is is it's
supposed to be oh so I'm like why if I'm
a rapper why am I on Twitter tweeting
about if I don't if I don't like so I
should make it creative yeah and I feel
like Tokyo snowtroopers it's pretty
creative my feelings I see so many more
great questions coming in from the fans
could you tell us something about the
survivor summer tour from Jose on
YouTube I can't tell you much about it
because I haven't confirmed when I'm
gonna go out okay on the road but I can
tell you that I have a tour deal with
Live Nation I actually have since around
Christmastime loss she is so I've always
had the intention of putting this
project out and going on tour that part
of it is set in stone I'd say I'll go on
tour in winter time okay
towards the end of the era off to
Christmas you'll be looking at seeing
me like fully touring again but I just
really want to put this project out and
enjoy it and I like to be conceptual
things so I would like to make sure that
the live stage show is like a visual
experience the way that my music videos
and things like that uh so I'm gonna
need time to really get that together
I had a full start with my last album
and ended up canceling my tour because
it wasn't creatively together and didn't
have the staging and things like that
together on time so I really want to
make sure that I don't miss step the
second time around with my planning and
things like I'm always late you copy
late for a live tour that's the problem
yeah that I've learned so yeah I do have
a Tori I have a touring do it so what's
happening it's okay it's not not I've
signed a contract yes okay I'm going on
tour
probably in winter time sometime okay
that's all I can say about it it's going
to be awesome
well I'm gonna go to Europe I'm gonna go
to South America Oh
universe I'll be there love it
connor from youtube wants to know what's
the next visual from the EP i don't know
yet originally i was going to shoot all
of the videos before and then put them
out each week but i took a risk and
decided instead to focus on cream mm-hmm
and focus i suppose more my budget
increase to make my dreams actualize
even though it looks like videos are
funny because they can look so simple
but they have a lot of like technical
feats sure and even though cream looks
really simple and it's just a house and
lights um to sync those lights and light
that house and sync every thinking time
was a big technical feat and it was like
a labor of love but it was also not
no-nobody skimped on the budget tell you
that even though it looks like Trap
House you know what I mean it's
beautiful yeah lightly aesthetically it
really
it really a lot of effort went into that
technically to get to to aesthetically
get that happening with the lighting and
the timing of everything happening there
with the lights live filming it like
that so I would want like I would want
that level of production on a live tour
as well and I I just I don't like to
compromise on my ideas when it comes to
like actualizing them so I felt like I
really think if I had to bet all my
money on one of these six things I would
put it on cream so I'm gonna really put
my effort and put my you know budget and
put some of my ideas I had for other
videos I'm gonna put everything into
cream and I'm gonna like I'm gonna place
my bet and I did so now that I've done
that and we're kind of close to the EP
coming out August 3rd I feel like I'm
gonna wait and see what people not truly
like from the other four tracks I don't
see what I shoot a visual too based on
that but everything has a treatment
written to it so it's kind of ready to
go I just I want to let I just want to
see what organically happens
sure now I want to talk about some of
the collaborations you've got on this EP
you've got obviously a cream you've got
something coming out with Wiz Khalifa
yeah
those are the only two yeah they're good
ones yeah
well who's left on your bucket list to
collaborate with so many people oh my
god so many Oh everyone ha ha ha good
answer
Co me definitely Missy Elliott right uh
yeah she's just um I just I would just
like to see her in person and cry yes
there's only two living people that I
really would die if I met and one I've
met Andre 3000 and then I see Elliot
knows it and I love to pump but Andre
Tupac and Missy are like the three
people that I just love forever forever
forever what an Andre mm accidentally
walked into my studio or one day when I
was recording and he was like is this
the wrong room and I was
that's my hello I love you I was gonna
let him walk out and not tell him that I
loved him but I couldn't hold it inside
no yeah I was like I'm so sorry that I
have to do this to you right now but I
have to tell you that I love you and I'm
obsessed with you and I've been in love
with you forever and you're the like
most greatest best thing ever and he was
like I really like your music too and I
was like that's just a reflex reaction
that you're having that you have feel
like you have to say that back but I
knew that you don't but it's okay I love
you goodbye for well studio seized on
the whole I wish that this were studio C
but it's not it's Studio B my room but
have fun I drew 3000 and then I just
went to the bathroom like a hundred
times that day so trying to see just a
walk by yeah just cuz he's such a genius
he's such a genius yeah oh yeah I know I
got to ask you about this fan
speculation that there were rumors that
you and Tyga were maybe more than
friends you were spotted holding hands
do something we weren't holding hands it
my boy walked at this where are the
pictures of me and Toby was there
nothing going on with you so many
pictures of me and T at Coachella having
fun so many pictures where are the
pictures of us holding hands if we were
doing all this hand-holding well you
were having fun we were having fun he's
been my friend for almost a decade now
that's it all right
are you dating no I won today I'm
available what are you looking for well
are you on dating apps like no how do
you find a man I don't maybe I should I
just feel like dating opposite to like I
don't know I guess I'm here talking to
you saying I want a man so I guess it's
obvious I want a man I don't want a man
actually I actually don't care or I'd be
on a dating app to be honest with you I
am single and I make jokes about it
because of course we'd all like love but
to be honest with you I'm really like
I'm not actively looking for a man or I
think I could find one yeah do you have
friends ever tried to set you up or
anything like that no I have had the
same friends for so long now I
feel like they already know that I'm
crazy oh my friends friends know well we
would also love to see you and demi
lovato get back together I would love
that too I'm doing a show with her for
the California State Fair in like two
weeks
oh really so I'm gonna see her actually
I need to call her about that because we
have songs together and we should
perform one together rap I'm opening for
her I'm her opening act today which is
cool cuz I just I don't know I love the
idea of that because she's my friend um
how's she doing your tweet to her was so
sweet after everything she was going
through I know I had known about it sure
close that's a close friend so I had
really wanted for her to be the one to
tell people that and I worried a lot
just as her friend that you know
something was gonna leak or somebody
would somehow like take that and use it
negatively against her or to make her
seem like she's got a secret you know so
it's not my business to say to your
friend like you need to
yeah but it's your friend you know you
worry and you're like oh my god my
friends she has this thing that people
could use against turns I really want
her to like right and she did um and I
didn't I didn't know she was recording
that song she didn't tell me that so
when I heard I heard it when everybody
else heard it and I just was really
proud of her that she was honest cuz
it's really hard to be honest with
yourself so to be honest with the whole
world about something that you've
struggled with very publicly I think
that it's very admirable and I was very
proud of her to see her write that song
and put it out and to see everybody's
reception being so understanding of
where she's I thought I was really cool
it must have been a relief to to have it
you know out in the open and you know
yeah her leading the charge of the
discussion you know I can't speak for
her but for me as her friend I was
I'm just so happy that you did this
because I think that her documentary
that she did like was really like a
defining career moment for her that
really helped people understand her more
so I felt like this is another just
opportunity for you to be human and like
just keep embracing it and so I'm so
glad as she did one of those
conversations been like between you and
you and she's cents oh we haven't spoken
about anything like that since really I
don't know I try to kind of I tried to
my my own business about that yeah I
just I try I try to give her her space
because I don't want to seem like one of
those like nosy friends you know you're
just there for support yeah I don't want
to I don't want to pry and be all in the
mom zone
okay you okay girl what's going on she
needs me shook oh yeah yeah this is a
great question actually from Lisa G she
wants to know how did Fame change you or
did it what is there anything that you
miss about being normal before you were
famous yeah a million things everything
no I don't miss everything there's some
perks
yeah like knowing that you could go out
and maybe like meet a random guy at the
grocery store I know I'm not gonna meet
any random guy at the grocery store cuz
I'm not going to the grocery store you
know just weird things like that you
miss like weird normal things that you
don't think about at all I think you'd
miss I miss doing thing normal normal
stuff like that or spontaneity the
ability to be spontaneous I try to be as
spontaneous as I can like today I went
to Universal City and I went on the
jurassic park ride i didn't plan to do
that so i try to take the opportunity to
be as spontaneous as possible but when
you do have fame you have to be safe and
things are a lot more pre-planned no
matter what it is that you're doing if I
go rollerskating I rent the whole roller
rink out and it's very it's just the
ability to be as like spontaneous
you are before you are famous just for
safety kind of Oh some of that gets
taken away from you so I just I sort of
miss being able to like just go with the
flow go with the flow a bit yeah I wish
I could do that a bit more that's
probably the number one thing I miss
spontaneity I wish they would have more
of that okay
Marnie from facebook wants to know what
do you do to stay mentally tough I don't
have this know like um special like
secret recipe yeah I think it's
different for everybody and it's
different on the day because sometimes I
have my bad days and sometimes I have my
good days I think the thing is just
always having something that keeps you
busy and keeps you hopeful and something
to look forward to
helps me not necessarily stay mentally
tough but at least motivated or able to
drown out any negative thoughts I'm
having not that I can silence them but I
can make them quieter in my brain if I
have something else that I can do but
that's I guess that's not only kind of
like secret I could I could give is
really idle time is always bad well
maybe you can give us these secrets to
that summer bod you got going on girl
oh you look thank you so good look at
this Instagram right here I mean what
are you doing to stay in shape a lot
what yeah that does not come easy folks
no it doesn't yeah I don't get to eat
all this stuff that I would like to eat
a bit and I do a lot of working out I've
actually lost a lot of weight which I'm
proud of you look great I was trying to
get back to my like on the roadshow rate
show weight because I not even weight
just physical fitness because I used to
be out touring and doing live shows so
much in so much cardio running around
dancing and stuff for an hour and I had
been
music and not really doing much for the
last couple of years so knowing that I
am gonna go on tour I really wanted this
summer to like not just get my buddy
back no I don't think I ever lost it but
for me it wasn't really like necessarily
about taking Instagram pictures I just I
really wanted to get back fit and back
healthy to put on a good show
cuz it's to two hours one of the hours
on stage of cardio and I want to be I
want to be fit and able to like do the
show do a bit of choreography you have
good voice control in those things so
just like getting more into into that
and trying to get prepared for that side
effect of that so what is your routine
like when you're not on the road because
wow I have to go in a meal plan usually
what is it just it's so well fish no I
don't really I'm not really into fish
okay bye like shrimp how did you I
didn't and then I did do you know your
palate changes yeah well I've always
wanted to like shrimp my whole life just
because they look so cool in shrimp
cocktails I know this is such a good
thing I'm excited to like shrimp but I
just never liked them and I've tried so
many times over the years like maybe
this is the year that I like shrimp yeah
no it's not so shrimp is on the menu now
okay I went to the Dominican Republic
I'm not gonna say who with so don't even
try but I went on it on a date with a
man friends with a man okay and it was
our first time not meeting but going on
some sort of romantic ish situation you
know okay like I met I hadn't met this
guy a bunch of other times and so who is
he I'm not gonna tell you it didn't work
out obviously but my point is it was a
over a year ago now but so I show up to
the Dominican Republic for this vacation
and he had like really planned
all of these nice mannish romantic like
gestures I just was like oh my god I
feel like so special that he had made
this like God in romantic lunch
situation and he had pre like ordered
the menu so the food was just coming out
and it was all like shrimp because I
really like this guy he's really hot
yeah and I really like him and I don't
want to blow the whole thing right now
by being like I'm sorry I have to tell
you that this pre-planned seafood menu
you have is just no work for me I was
like I'm just gonna force myself to like
shrimp today and finally enough the
shrimp was really tasty that day and
ever since then maybe he was just really
cute I don't know but I like shrimp now
guys very I do I've eaten it all the
time since just to make sure it wasn't
just that I liked the guy that was
making me fake like shrimp I really like
shrimp I don't know how they prepared it
that one time the relationship didn't
last but the love of shrimp did yeah I
went so friends he's cool he's my bad
guy okay
I mean he eats too much seafood for me
you still didn't answer my question
though what like what are you eating
like what's your meal plan and what your
workout routine
well my meal plan sucks I want to eat
like macaroni and cheese no I mean this
is real talk like it's I think real need
to know to look like that like that's
not fun
no to be honest with you icon I don't do
it all the time I'll do it for a month
or six weeks and then give myself a
break for a little bit just because it's
too strict of a diet for me to be able
to follow it all the time bye I am
really good if I have like a short-term
goal sticking to it so I can follow like
a very strict diet or anything he told
me to do for a couple of weeks but to do
it
yeah like indefinitely I just mentally
can't
sure do that but it's like well for me I
do it's only 1,500 calories is the for
my buddy that's not saying you should do
that because you have to have a
nutritionist to see what your present
intake is to cut down and stuff but it's
a lot of zucchinis it's like this much
meat yeah me and there's never bread or
pasta or if it is posture it's really
vegetables that have been like fake made
to look like pasta which is the meanest
trick spiralled vegetables it's really
not very fun sometimes they make cookies
that I get sent which if I get sent a
cookie it's a good day but yeah okay
they're okay they're okay but it's yeah
it's usually like a very large like this
big portion of some sort of vegetable
and then like this big portion of some
kind of meat and it's largely vegetables
it really makes a big difference I'd say
mostly in what you eat plays a way
larger role than the amount of like
physical exercise that you're doing
because you can do so much physical
exercise and eat what you want and it
you just doesn't unfortunately
it's paying off girl cuz your instagrams
are fine is there ever anything that is
too hot to post because the mr. Graham
gets touchy about the censoring
sometimes and you my friend sometimes
will push the boundaries like this one
right here but it doesn't technically
show anything no there's no boob and
there's technically or is it a leg
debatable oh good good call what is
there ever like where you're like I
don't know if I should post this is this
too much or with anything goes I'm
pretty risqué yeah
so I guess for me I like to be
polarizing so if I was like I don't know
then that would probably make me be out
yes yeah maybe one pitch oh that's a
black-and-white picture where you can
see my nipples and breasts I guess I
thought about that not because I wasn't
sure if I wanted people to see my
breasts because I already went to
Fashion Week and Asha top like with me
as one does personally I had already
painted my nipples red and dived in a
pool in a video so I already know I'm
cool with boobs
they don't really offend me maybe
because I grew up where I grew up we
have nude beaches and so I just didn't I
don't really feel breast sexual but they
can also be neutral to me or where I
grew up it's not unusual at all to see
people like laying on the beach naked or
I grew up with friends who whose mothers
would like walk around the house with
that top up sometimes if they're in the
pool and answer the door and be like
Hello person that's coming to hang out
with my friend I'm like it's very like
very airy-fairy where I grew up so I
just don't know I was like I really have
an issue I really have a hangout with
boobs
do you ever does Instagram ever flag you
and oh yeah they stay they have taken my
boobs downs yeah I guess the only thing
I think about is like will people judge
me for this or think that whatever but I
I just I don't know I can't really not
do something based on that so yeah I'm
like I think it's a beautiful picture
and I didn't plan on taking it that way
but when I was testing out the lighting
and I'm thinking that I was gonna pose
like you know covering it up
strategically I was like I actually
think it's nice that opposed say and so
I just do it's just what felt like it's
what so like the best pose to me I
didn't like put it on and think like I'm
gonna show my boobs today I thought I
would go like this but then I was like
this just feel
so constricting and just weird so I'm
just yeah I noticed your tattoo earlier
on your fingers yes yes when'd you get
that one a while ago I want to say like
maybe you lost September oh yeah yeah I
found rest inator so I have to tattoo
things on me to make myself to them oh
so you tattooed that on yourself to make
the EP yeah digital just Russian I
didn't even put that one out how do you
decide when you're like okay this needs
to be tattooed on shore I don't know I
don't know how do you decide I get I
don't know it's just it's just a vibe
you just know yeah you know I don't have
any so I don't know I'm scared of them I
have like half sleeve and I have a
tattoo on my butt but that's it Oh a my
foot that's it yeah I'm done just a few
casual you're done
no way no I really am I heard it's so
addicting I don't think it's addicting
no maybe because it's mmm I could see
how it would be addicting do you have
your first one maybe wanting another one
straight away but I think once you have
a certain amount maybe the thrill wears
off a bit cuz I just don't really feel I
wouldn't want to tattoo beyond my you
know what's this forearm yeah
personally so okay I'm good
well before I let you go I want to thank
you so much for being so generous with
your time today there's another fan
question on here from Ash on Facebook
that I think is really great about the
music she says do you think there's a
difference when men write song about
exes or past relationships versus when a
woman does it yes there's many
differences but in which exact way in
the reception of a woman discussing that
or I don't know that's what what ash
wants to know I would say maybe what do
you think exactly I mean the way people
say away when talking about yes I think
that's what she means yeah I think that
definitely is that definitely is I mean
look at Taylor Swift
she gets so much [ __ ] about talking
about her relationships and then there
are so many men that do the same thing
and we don't have anything to say about
that I don't know why I feel like
there's always this assumption that the
woman gets left and that they're like
bitter and sad about it like I'll have
people say to me a lot I don't know why
your ex would leave you and it's like
who said he left me why is that the
assumption that a what happened so I
think like just like knowing things
seeing things like that little things
like that um for me as a woman not just
as a songwriter I'm like I think there's
like the undercurrent of like under turn
perception whether people realize it or
not of like that I don't know why then
women are like being left and they're
sad about it and they angry about it and
a bitter about it and it's like mmm I
don't think they are I think women
should be able to talk about their exes
if they're songwriters it's part of like
life and you want to have like an old
encompassing experience getting to know
the artist and them to be able to share
like things that affect them emotionally
a relationship is gonna be one of those
things so I do notice like the
difference in perception when a woman
releases a song about an ex-lover or
mentions an ex-lover and I think like
that it's definitely received
differently but it shouldn't be no you
like to stir the pox I do like to start
apart when you're making your music to
be honest I I don't only because I
haven't had an actual relationship in
over two years so for me there's just
not any like residual feelings about any
ex relationships that I feel like I
would want to write about so it just
wouldn't be authentic to me at this
point in my life to be talking
about something that I experienced that
was that far in the past it would be
like it just wouldn't be right
I just don't I have to really when I
write sewing I really mean it
like I'm riled up and I'm like you know
so like a relationship or anything
that's not old to me it's just even if
it was a feeling of happiness um it's
just not gonna have that like strength
of when something's fresh something good
that's fresh something bad whatever it
is like it's just not gonna trigger my
creativity or spark something in me when
it's that far gone if it didn't have
like a lasting effect on me so no I
wouldn't but maybe if I had a
relationship in future and it left a
dent on me for whatever reason or there
was a breakup would I talk about it oh
I'm talking but nothing nothing in my
album or EP I don't have any goes I ate
shrimp once with a guy like I caught me
a song about shrimp like I just don't
have enough emotional content to talk
about that kind of thing
well I'm really excited to hear what you
do have in store for a big like I have
good in my bag getting to the money
anthems we gots my feelings at the
moment they're all about like power yeah
boobs that's what I'm feeling inside I'm
just not really in a love mood and
that's fine
I'm just not and that's totally fine but
still call me if you're cute to call I
might be in a love mood maybe you could
make me in one but I'm just not really
if the mood strikes I'm never getting to
the money mood okay yeah money moods I'm
in a money mood yeah yeah I think seeing
all the girls really like cream and
saying open up the safe I'm like yeah
I'm staying in my money movie in my
money mood for a while all right
killing it girl thank you so much for
being here
thank you survive the summer is out
August 3rd it's available for pre-order
now so you guys can check it out
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you